so I have data here on two different
websites website a and website B and my
question to you is which one is more
productive and some of you might be
asking yourself what does it mean to be
productive and at a very high level you
could view productivity as how effective
something is at producing so for a given
amount of input into the process how
much output are you getting if you want
to get a little bit more exact you could
view it as the rate of output per input
but that still makes us ask the question
what are the inputs and what are the
outputs so pause this video and think
about how you would measure productivity
for or how you would compare the
productivity of these two websites and
there's multiple ways to do it all right
now let's think through it together what
I'm first going to do is look at each of
these lines and think about whether they
are an input or an output so the number
of writers well you need the writers to
produce the website so I would consider
that an input although if you were the
head of HR the person who is hiring
writers the head of Human Resources and
you are hiring writers and that could
actually be an output but if we're just
thinking about creating a website we
need writers to create it so that's an
input number of posts posted average
number of words of post average likes of
post average comments of post number of
new subscribers those all feel like
outputs if the writers do a good job
they're going to produce a lot of posts
they're going to I guess have a lot of
words I don't know if it's good to
always be wordy people will like their
posts they'll comment on those posts
will have new subscribers so this is all
output what about revenue that's how
much money a site brings in before
having to pay its expenses so that also
should be an output because if the
writers do a good job if the site is
well run they will generate a lot of
revenue what about expenses well you
need to use expenses you just spend
expenses
on things like rider salaries in order
to create your website in order to
generate that revenue so I would
consider that an input and what about
profit profit is all the money you bring
in minus your expenses and how much you
get left over well some people would
argue the whole point of a business is
to generate that profit that is an
outcome you want to maximize as an
output and so I would consider that an
output and so the question of per
activity really just boils down to which
output or what combinations of output do
we want to figure out the rate that
we're generating relative to some input
or some combination of inputs so a
really simple way of measuring
productivity in this situation let's
define it productivity and once again
there's multiple ways of defining it
let's say it is equal to the profit per
number of riders so it could be profit
over the number of writers if we define
it that way which website is more
productive well website a in that
definition a would have a productivity
of ten thousand dollars for five riders
so it would be two thousand dollars
profit per writer and what would be what
would be bees per activity by this
definition well twenty eight thousand
dollars divided by eleven twenty eight
thousand divided by eleven riders those
twenty eight thousand dollars in profit
that case this is two thousand and we'll
around two thousand five hundred and
forty five so approximately two thousand
five hundred and forty five dollars of
profit per writer so based on this
measurement of productivity it looks
like website B is more productive now
what if we do did maybe even a simpler
one or maybe one that you might think is
even more natural what if we thought
about it as the number of posts per
writer so let's do it that way
if we just defined productivity I'll
just do that as being equal to the
number of posts divided by the writers
well in this situation website a would
have a productivity of a hundred and ten
divided by five which would be twenty to
twenty-two posts per writer and website
be two hundred divided by eleven two
hundred divided by eleven gets us we old
ik adjusts around that to maybe eighteen
since we want to get rough estimates to
eighteen posts per writer so by this
measure of productivity website a
actually looks more productive so
hopefully this gives you just a general
sense of what productivity is and an
appreciation that there's multiple ways
of measuring it and you could do much
fancier things you could say you could
make it a whole combination of outputs
divided by a combination of inputs so
you could define productivity as the
number of post posted times the average
number of posts you take that quantity
and then maybe add the average likes per
post or multiplied by the average likes
proposed and then add to that the
comments per post or multiplied by the
comments proposed and then divide by the
number of writers or the number of
writers and the expenses or divide just
by the expenses but the general notion
is you want to divide some you want to
take some combination of the outputs
maybe even just one output and divide it
by some combination of the inputs and
you can actually decide how you even
want to combine how do you want to
mathematically combine those outputs and
inputs